Und schon wieder das ist wirklich der hammer immer wieder werden neue schwarze löcher entdeckt
Und immer wieder gibt es neue hinweise auf noch mehr schwarze löcher
Müssen wir jetzt wirklich langsam die theorie der dunkle materie über den haufen werfen
Sind die schwarzen löcher einfach die triebfeder von allem. Im universum ja es liegt nahe. Jetzt den klicks 1 infektion herzlich willkommen
Also jetzt mal ganz
Konzentriert wenn ich mir, so ansehe wie oft ich in letzter zeit videos über schwarze löcher und ihre bedeutung gemacht
Habe wahnsinn und wenn ich das alles mal so zusammenfassen dann ist das wirklich ziemlich
Beeindruckend jedes mal kommen da raus es sind mehr sie spielen eine größere rolle
Und es gibt theorien die sagen dass sie die dunkle materie sind aber erstmal eine
Aktuelle studie es wurden in der vergangenheit ja schon ziemlich
gigantische schwarze löcher gefunden die ohne
Galaxie wo wir eigentlich im zentrum seien müssten durch das all fliegen es wird vermutet dass sie bei
kollisionen von galaxien ins all geschleudert worden jetzt hat aber eine forschungsgruppe hinweise auf zusätzliche
Supermassereiche schwarze löcher in den außenbereichen von galaxien gefunden michael tremmel von der yale university in den usa
Hat mit, seinem team jedenfalls einen auf galaxienentstehung
spezialisiertes programm simulationen erstellen lassen und das ergebnis sind zusätzliche
supermassereiche schwarze löcher die befinden sich in der halo also dem außenbereich von
galaxien ursache sind wohl die kollisionen von galaxien miteinander nach denen diese
supermassereichen schwarzen löcher eben nicht in das zentrum der neuen zusammen gebildeten galaxie gestürzt sind sondern eben im
außenbereich geblieben sind
im gegensatz zum
normalfall zitat es kann aber auch vorkommen dass dieser prozess stoppt und die
supermassereichen schwarzen löcher das galaktische zentrum gar nicht erreichen so das forschungsteam
also
Der prozess des ins zentrum stürzen der wird dann gestoppt und das forschungs 7 hat auch ausgerechnet wie viele dieser
supermassereichen schwarzen löcher sich im außenbereich einer galaxie befinden es sind mehr als 4
supermassereiche schwarze löcher also insgesamt gibt es demnach, im universum fünfmal mehr
supermassereiche schwarze löcher mit millionen und milliarden sonnenmassen als bisher angenommen und das ist nicht das erste mal dass
Zusätzliche schwarze löcher entdeckt werden er ist letztlich wurde er festgestellt dass es viel mehr
Riesige sterne gibt als bisher angenommen untersuchungsobjekt war die magellansche wolke
Im dortigen stern bildungssektor 30 dorados gibt es tausendmal mehr
Sonnenmassen die dort pro jahr entstehen und was da entsteht ist absolut spektakulär und wirft alles um denn es werden dort vielmehr große
massereiche sterne produziert als eigentlich bisher angenommen und das ist wirklich frappierend zitat wir waren enorm
Überrascht als wir feststellten dass 30 uhr asus so viel mehr
Massereiche sterne gebildet hat als erwartet so erst autor fabian schneider von der oxford university
Sie sind zwar immer noch seltener als kleinere sterne wie unsere sonne aber sie machen einen deutlich größeren anteil am
Gesamtgewicht aus weil sie so viel schwerer sind ein beispiel ist
r136a1 der blaue riese der wird auf
300 sonnenmassen geschätzt und leuchtet achtung
8,7 millionen mal heller als die sonne
waren sind zitat unsere ergebnisse legen
Nahe dass der größte anteil der gesamten stern maxe nicht
Im massearmen sternen steckt erklärt mitautor chris evans vom royal
Observatorien edinburgh die ergebnisse sind absolut umwerfend sie bedeuten dass es rund 70 prozent mehr
Supernovae gibt als bisher angenommen und weiter aus diesen
riesenstern entstehen mehr und größere schwarze löcher da viele dieser riesensterne zu schwarzen löchern zusammenhang vermuten die
Wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler dass und jetzt bitte hinsetzen es dreimal so viele schwarze löcher gibt als bisher
gedacht
Also immer mehr und auch immer mehr und größere schwarze löcher die gefunden werden und da bin ich wieder bei meiner
lieblings theorie was wäre wenn der
hauptbestandteil des weltalls schwarze löcher
Wären also masse mäßig dann gäbe es keine dunkle materie und die schwarzen löcher müssten die fehlende masse
darstellen weswegen die dunkle materie
Vermutet wird warum das ist ganz simpel womit wir dabei wären das plötzlich alles ganz einfach
Wäre die dunkle materie ist ja vermutet und noch nicht bewiesen mit ihrer gravitation
Dafür verantwortlich dass sich galaxien anders verhalten als sie würden wenn sie nur aus materie bestehen würden also
Sichtbarer materie die sternsysteme am äußeren rand bewegen sich viel schneller als erwartet also wenn nur die sichtbare materie vorhanden wäre aber genau
dieses verhalten könnten ebenso schwarze löcher verursachen sie kennen wir schon und wir wissen sehr
Genau was sie verursachen nämlich
Genau das und wenn man sich auf wikipedia den ersten satz zur aktuellen beschreibung der dunkle materie ansieht dann ist das eine
absolute erleuchtung dunkle materie ist eine postulierte form von materie die nicht direkt
Sichtbar ist aber über die gravitation wechsel wird und auf was trifft
Genau diese beschreibung zu exakt auf schwarze löcher das würde auch erklären
Warum die seltsamen teilchen der dunklen materie nie gefunden wurden und es gibt eine wissenschaftliche arbeit dazu alexander
Kaczynski vom goddard space flight center der nasa hat dazu eine studie veröffentlicht und die ist simpel und einfach
mind blowing seine these zuerst sind in unserem universum
Die schwarzen löcher entstanden sogenannte primor die aale schwarze löcher sie bilden die dunkle materie und haben überhaupt dafür
Gesorgt dass die materie die nicht in sie gestürzt ist sterne
sternsysteme und galaxien bilden konnte sie war nämlich eigentlich zu heiß dafür die schwarzen löcher
Haben sie durch ihre gravitation erst so komprimiert dass sie gestirnen bilden konnte zitat
Diese studie macht sich zum anliegen verschiedene ideen und beobachtungen zusammen zu bringen und zu untersuchen wie gut sie zusammenpassen
Und sie passen überraschend gut sagt kaschins trieb wenn das alles korrekt ist dann sind alle galaxien
eingeschossen unsere eigenen in eine gewaltige sphäre von schwarzen löchern
eingebettet von denen jedes rund 30 mal massereicher ist als die sonne die coolsten schwarzen löcher und die durch das verschmelzen von schwarzen löchern
Entstanden sind haben dann materie um sich gesammelt und so die galaxien gebildet und diese sphäre von schwarzen löchern
Die scheint jetzt stück für stück entdeckt zu werden wenn ihr als erstes neues zu diesem thema
So schwarze löcher und dunkle materie und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer ihr
Whats app dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich garantiert und für
jeden der
Drauf klickt gibt es in der begrüßungs nachricht ein kleines cooles cody einfach hier draufklicken und gut durchlesen und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau glocker vergessen hier geht es weiter also hier dafür auch. Draufklicken klicken die geschichte des universums
Muss umgeschrieben werden da geht es auch, um dieses thema etwas ausführlicher ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran